Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Il est 7h05 du matin.
Je me réveille en sursaut.
Le surveillant de l’étage ouvre
les portes des cellules une à une.
Mon tour arrive.
Je sers le ventre,
je me bouche les oreilles.
(Bruits d’une serrure qu’on déverrouille)
J’ai l’impression qu’on m’arrache le cœur.
Avec le temps, j’ai pris l’habitude
d’anticiper ce réveil brutal
et de me lever plus tôt.
À l’ouverture de la porte de ma cellule,
je suis assis sur ma chaise et je dis :
« Bonjour, surveillant. »
Puis je prends mon café et une douche.
À 8 heures,
j’appelle mes parents
depuis la cabine de l’étage
avant de me rendre
soit en formation, soit en cours
ou au travail si ma demande
a été acceptée.
Après l’activité du matin,
les après-midis, je fais du sport
pour éviter de prendre du poids.
Mais le rendez-vous le plus important,
c’est le parloir.
J’ai de la chance,
ma famille ne m’abandonne pas.
C’est le rendez-vous à ne pas manquer ;
je stresse.
À chaque parloir, mon père me dit :
« J’espère que tu vas changer pour toi.
Fini les conneries.
- Oui, papa !
Fini les conneries, promis !  »
À côté de moi, j’ai ma mère qui donne un
coup de pied à mon père pour lui dire :
« C’est bon, il a compris. »
J’ai mis du temps à comprendre,
mais, oui, j’ai compris.
Pendant sept ans,
ma famille a parcouru jusqu’à 700 km
pour venir me voir une heure au parloir.
Dans le froid, sous la pluie,
le verglas, la canicule.
Pour mes parents, il n’y a pas
de dimanche ensoleillé.
Avec mes enfants, je suis en train
de rater beaucoup de choses :
les accompagner à l’école,
fêter leurs anniversaires,
les fêtes de fin d’année,
et les petites joies du quotidien.
Ils ont fait quoi pour mériter ça ?
Ici, autour de moi,
les détenus font leur peine seuls.
Beaucoup de couples se séparent
et beaucoup de pères galèrent pour
faire venir au parloir leurs enfants.
Sans le soutien de la famille,
pour eux, c’est encore plus dur.
Mais il fallait réfléchir avant.
On ne nous a pas enfermés pour rien.
En prison,
tout peut arriver à n’importe quel moment.
Souvent une cellule de 12 m² est partagée
par deux, voire trois détenus.
C'est difficile à vivre.
Pour garder les liens avec l'extérieur,
les détenus prennent des risques.
Ils font entrer des téléphones portables,
de la drogue ou d’autres objets interdits,
et souvent se font prendre.
Les sanctions sont multiples :
quartier disciplinaire où on est privé
de tout ce qu’on a dans une cellule -
télé, frigo, vêtements personnels -
retrait des réductions de peine
et sanctions pénales
si les faits sont graves.
J’ai connu quelqu’un entré pour six mois
et sorti trois ans après
pour mauvais comportement.
Durant mon incarcération,
j’ai effectué un an d’isolement,
car j’ai eu le malheur
de craquer pour une surveillante.
J’étais coupé de tout lien
avec les autres détenus :
pas d’activités collectives,
pas de terrain de foot.
Le temps est long à l'isolement.
Parfois, je parlais tout seul.
J’aurais pu me cachetonner
et passer la journée allongé au lit,
me laisser abattre
en regardant les chaînes d’info.
Non.
J’ai préféré mettre ma haine
dans ma réflexion.
Pour ne pas devenir fou
et comprendre ce que dit la loi,
j’ai commencé à noter sur des bouts
de papier les délits les plus courants :
agressions, vols, discrimination, trafic.
La directrice de la maison d’arrêt
a accepté de me prêter
le seul code pénal de la prison.
J’ai noté à la main
chaque article de ce pavé.
J’ai toujours la marque du stylo
sur mon doigt.
En sortant de prison, j’ai vu
qu’avec la technologie,
il suffisait juste
de faire un copier-coller.
Sans le savoir, j’étais en train
de créer un jeu de société
basé sur le système judiciaire
et le milieu carcéral.
J'ai demandé au psychologue son grand
calendrier qui m'a servi de plateau.
J’ai noté toutes les activités
proposées en détention.
Ce projet m’a permis
de tenir bon à l’isolement
et surtout de me projeter pour la suite.
Plus le temps passait,
plus le projet prenait forme.
Je suis sorti de prison le 26 mars 2020,
en plein confinement.
(Rires)
Je me suis retrouvé enfermé
chez mes parents, mais j’étais heureux.
La galère était derrière moi, mais enfin,
je pouvais aller au bout de mon projet.
J’ai concentré mon énergie
pour sortir mon jeu
et la presse en a beaucoup parlé.
J'ai fait de très belles rencontres.
Le jeu s’appelle RPS pour
« Remise de Peine Supplémentaire ».
Il est sorti le 27 juillet 2020.
C’est un outil de sensibilisation
et de prévention de la délinquance.
Le principe du jeu est de montrer
le parcours du combattant
pour cumuler les RPS
en faisant des efforts de réinsertion,
tout en évitant les fautes disciplinaires.
Chaque joueur tire une carte, prend
connaissance du délit qu’il a commis,
de la peine encourue,
et de l’amende qui va avec.
Le reste des cases présente le reste
des activités proposées en détention.
Le but du jeu est de sortir de prison
le plus rapidement possible.
Mon histoire a attiré l’attention
des éducateurs spécialisés
et des associations.
Ce jeu me permet d’aller à la rencontre
des jeunes et des professionnels.
Mon parcours me donne la légitimité de
montrer que ce n’est pas le Club Med
et que la délinquance ne paye pas.
Certains jeunes n'ont plus
peur de la police.
Ils ont une méconnaissance de la loi.
D’autres ont même envie d’aller en prison,
me dit-on presque à chaque intervention.
Ils pensent qu’une fois sortis de prison,
ils vont devenir de vrais caïds.
En jouant à RPS,
la prise de conscience est immédiate.
Je travaille dans toute la France
et ce que les jeunes me racontent
me terrifie.
Des gamins de 12, 13 ans prennent
des coups dans des halls d’immeuble
pour tester leur capacité
à supporter sans parler.
C’est la méthode employée
par les dealers pour les recruter.
Ensuite, ils deviendront des guetteurs
pour 50 euros par jour.
Certains sont même prêts
à le faire pour un kebab.
Tôt ou tard, ça les enverra en prison.
Quel gâchis !
Quel temps perdu !
Les jeunes se font manipuler
par les trafiquants,
comme quoi ils ne risquent pas grand-chose
quand ils sont mineurs.
Ce n’est pas vrai.
Le Code pénal des mineurs existe
et la prison pour mineurs aussi.
On ne fait pas assez de prévention
auprès des jeunes.
Lors de mes interventions, je leur montre
tout ce qu’ils ont à perdre
et tout ce que j’ai perdu.
À chaque fois,
je reçois un accueil incroyable de la part
des jeunes et des professionnels.
Les éducateurs me disent :
« Arbi, tu fais comment pour les tenir
concentrés pendant cinq heures ?
D’habitude, avec nous, au bout
de 20 minutes, c’est le bordel. »
C'est vrai.
Cet outil pédagogique intéresse
les médiateurs, les associations,
les formateurs, les éducateurs
spécialisés, les mairies.
J’ai découvert un métier,
je suis devenu intervenant.
Je leur dis que
la délinquance ne paye pas.
Je leur dis aussi qu’ils ont
la possibilité d’être informés
des conséquences de leurs actes.
Moi, je n'ai pas eu cette chance.
À chaque fois, je passe des super
moments d’échange et de partage.
Mais à la fin, je pars avec le sentiment
de les abandonner.
Je suis arrivé en France
en 1996 d’Albanie.
J'avais 16 ans.
Je ne parlais pas français,
je n’avais pas de diplôme
et j’étais demandeur d’asile.
Je rêvais de devenir
joueur professionnel de foot,
mais ce rêve a pris fin
suite à une grave blessure au genou.
J’ai obtenu mon premier titre
de séjour en 2002.
J’ai travaillé comme agent
de sécurité pendant trois ans.
À cette époque, je traînais
avec des délinquants.
Ils avaient les poches pleines
et ils roulaient dans de belles voitures.
On m'a proposé de vendre
200 grammes de cocaïne.
Je savais que je pouvais faire de
l’argent même si je n’avais pas un client.
J’ai dit oui sans hésiter,
sans prendre en compte les risques.
Je suis devenu dealer.
Je n'étais pas né dealer.
Je n’ai pas pensé à ma famille,
ni aux conséquences.
Concernant les consommateurs, j’ai pris
conscience bien plus tard des dégâts.
Quand Hubert, un détenu
que je voyais tous les jours,
est mort par overdose
à côté de ma cellule.
La prévention de la délinquance,
ça marche.
Je le constate tous les jours.
La prise de conscience est immédiate.
Dans un centre éducatif fermé,
un jeune homme m’a dit :
« Arbi, je me rends compte que
si je continue, je vais gâcher ma vie.
Merci pour tout ce que tu nous
as apporté aujourd’hui.
Des histoires vraies, c'est ce qu'on veut.
Avec le jeu, on apprend mieux.
Et toi, tu ne nous fais pas la morale,
tu nous parle comme à des petits frères. »
Aujourd’hui, je me trouve devant vous.
Je veux que vous sachiez que ma libération
conditionnelle est finie depuis 48 heures.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Grâce à RPS le jeu,
je suis devenu chef d’entreprise et j’ai
développé deux autres jeux de prévention.
J’ai l’ambition de recruter un ancien
détenu dans chaque région de France
pour qu’il puisse faire de la prévention
auprès des jeunes.
Ils seront des intervenants,
je participerai à leur réinsertion.
La prévention, ça marche.
Mais pour que je puisse effectuer
encore plus largement ma mission,
j’ai besoin de l’appui des élus
et des autres acteurs qui se consacrent
à la prévention de la délinquance.
J’ai besoin qu’on m’ouvre les portes
des lycées et des collèges.
Je veux leur dire que faire le guetteur
pour un kebab ne vaut pas le coup.
Vraiment pas.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)